[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes les opérations
militaires viennent de commencer en irak
la france regrette cette action engagée
sans l'aval des nations unies
je souhaite que ces opérations soient
les plus rapides et les moins meurtrière
possible et qu'elle ne conduise pas à
une catastrophe humanitaire jusqu'au
bout la france avec bien d'autres pays
s'est efforcé de convaincre que le
nécessaire d armement de l'irak
pouvaient être obtenues par des voies
pas si ses efforts n'ont pas abouti
quelle que soit la durée de ce conflit
il sera lourd de conséquences pour
l'avenir
la france fidèle à ses principes
primauté du droit
équité dialogue entre les peuples et
respect des autres continuera à agir
pour que les crises qui ensanglantent ou
menace le monde trouve des solutions
justes et durables dans l'action
collective
c'est à dire dans le cadre des nations
unies seul cadre légitime pour
construire la paix en irak comme
ailleurs
[Musique]